la embajada de estados unidos en cuba
volverá a funcionar que la embajada de
los eeuu en la habana
iniciará la reanudación limitada
de algunos servicios de visado de
inmigrante sin embargo no hay fecha
concreta para la reactivación de los
servicios consulares el cierre había
sido ordenado en septiembre de 2017 por
el entonces presidente de donald trump
quien acusó a cuba de atacar a sus
diplomáticos con supuestas armas sónicas
y es que al menos 24 diplomáticos habían
sufrido migrañas náuseas y leves daños
cerebrales provocados por la extraña
enfermedad apodada síndrome de la habana
los primeros casos aparecieron a finales
de 2016 poco más de un año después de la
reactivación de las relaciones
diplomáticas entre la isla comunista y
eeuu negociada por el régimen de raúl
castro y la administración obama una
investigación de la cia está en marcha
para tratar de entender el enigma el
régimen cubano siempre negó estar detrás
del síndrome que desde entonces se ha
extendido hasta moscú y poco a poco al
resto del mundo china georgia y más
recientemente colombia la reapertura del
consulado de estados en cuba se produce
en un momento en el que la isla
atraviesa su peor crisis económica en al
menos 30 años por el efecto de la
pandemia y el esfuerzo de las sanciones
estadounidenses lo que llevó a muchos
cubanos a buscar emigrar a eeuu algunos
por el mar y otros a través de
centroamérica pese a que en 2017 se
eliminó la política de pies secos-pies
mojados que permitía a los cubanos
permanecer en el país y solicitar la
residencia permanente